i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight thanks for
joining us
playing women for fools that's the focus
of tonight's angle
all right joe biden is lacing america
with misery as far as the eye can see
americans of all backgrounds are looking
across a dismal economic landscape
the signs of despair you see them i see
them they're building
and the fury is growing toward president
biden it is astounding
now i don't love drowning you all in
numbers i hate that but i'm going to
make an exception tonight because it's
that important
66 disapproval for biden's handling of
the economy
my question is who are these 34 percent
who approve of it as for scranton joe's
answers for the middle class only 36
percent say he's helping with the middle
class that's down from
a whole five percent from february
and americans see what's happening i
think look at this they're getting
poorer as days go on
they remember how biden's dimwitted
treasury secretary janet yellen remember
when she just brushed off inflation
concerns a year ago we made a big deal
of it here on the angle and today
we saw a historic rate hike
a desperate move with terrible
consequences for hard-working americans
interest rate hikes mean it will be more
expensive to borrow money if you're
trying to buy a home experts say the
asking price may not be much higher than
it is now but the cost to buy that house
is going to be higher so because
mortgage rates are going up that means
many new homeowners will not only be
paying higher interest on their
mortgages but could also get less house
for their money
oh great and if you've built up some
credit card debt over the past year
if you've got credit card debt it's
going to cost you more if you're buying
a car it's going to cost you more
because the rates of the to borrow that
money to get that car is going to go up
now it's infuriating and just a few
years ago you all remember this under
trump
economic optimism as looking back in
november and december 2019 it was
climbing
young americans minorities women of all
backgrounds had record low unemployment
those rising wages no inflation no new
wars cheap gas
and now
everything's going in the wrong
direction and on top of that
everyone's being told oh just lower your
expectations what can many of us do to
brace for these higher interest rates
that are coming the analysts we spoke to
say if you can hold off on that major
purchase of a house or a car that you've
been thinking about hold that offer as
long as you can for some they say it's
time to think outside the box regarding
your living situation living with
relatives or sharing a residence with
anyone else they say they can have that
can help you ride out some of these rate
hikes
yeah you want to move back home live
with mommy and daddy right
so naturally this is in this entire
grim environment with a midterm wipeout
looming for the democrats
they're just left to cater wall from
stage left
fear-mongering and lying about the
court's draft decision to overturn roe
just like they did during covet
make no mistake
this is about controlling women
far-right politicians are working to
restrict all family planning services
denying a whole generation of women the
freedom to plan for their future now
nevada's cortez masto has no answers on
new mexico's inflation the illegal
immigration issue that's plaguing the
state but she does have talking points
from planned parenthood yay
first the issue is just returned to the
states apparently she doesn't understand
how to read a legal draft opinion second
uh the congresswoman uh or senator
thinks so little of women's intelligence
that she believes women can only plan
pregnancies by aborting their offspring
how insulting
and another effort to change the subject
came from the woman who's a heartbeat
away from the presidency yet pretends
that liberation is found in stopping the
heartbeats of the unborn those
republican leaders who are trying to
weaponize the use of the law against
women
will we say
how dare they
how dare they tell a woman what she can
do and cannot do with her own body how
dare they
try to deny women
their rights
and their freedoms
she just hopes the prompter doesn't go
down well she's just another democrat
who doesn't trust the voters to make
decisions for themselves she'd rather
have nine unelected justices make those
decisions
well until at least the ruling went the
other way
then she's left sputtering inane
platitudes about bodily autonomy after
she and her party still try to force
vaccines on women who didn't want them
none of this by the way is principled
but she's so apoplectic about the gop
tsunami that's about to swamp them
she's even trying to convince you that
the movement that resulted in 50 million
babies being aborted
is
wait for it it's patriotic
if you stand
for freedom
for self-determination
for the right to privacy
if you stand
for these principles
stand with us
because you see
women's issues
are america's issues let us fight for
our country
and for the principles upon which it was
founded and let us fight with everything
we have got
god bless you and god bless america
so now she's saying the principles on
which it was found in the country
including aborting children
no one believes that it's not going to
work
now back in the 70s 80s even into the
90s many liberals supported abortion for
sure but now
liberalism is defined by abortion
there are no real pro-life democrats in
congress and good luck finding one in
your friend group
liberals in 2022 have zero hesitation
about things like selling out to china a
dictatorship that brutalizes women who
are uyghurs or christians or who just
are women who want to have big families
liberals in 2022 line up with the
military industrial complex which wants
war with russia
liberals in 2022 support restrictions on
movement citing climate change which is
why they love the lockdowns
liberals in 2022 support restrictions on
speech under the bogus rationale of
disinformation
and those same liberals who used to be
about tolerance
now cite hate speech to bar people from
speaking in public to be part of public
life
of course their definition of hate
speech is purposely vague it's always
changing
suffice it to say that liberals who say
things that denigrate entire groups of
americans based on political affiliation
they're never guilty of hate speech
they've evolved and changed and gone 180
liberals have on so many issues
but not on this one
it doesn't matter how much fetal
medicine has improved or imaging
or the wide array of birth control
that's available
or the number of couples desperate to
adopt
democrats have become abortion fanatics
it's the most important issue among a
handful of issues that make up their
holy grail of issues
it's a dreary dark world they're
creating
and one where women are the ones who
really end up suffering the most
the left's answer to everything is i
don't know it's kind of summed up by
more pot more porn more abortions more
sexual identity indoctrination in
schools more racial recriminations more
american traditions trashed more statues
smashed
their idea of empowerment includes
lovely activities like [ __ ] walks
one leftist writer in salon recently
argued that women's path to happiness
means shrugging off prudence and proudly
embracing promiscuity
but i think women are onto this game
they're onto the game that the democrats
have been playing for a while now
because they feel it they know it life
is getting harder for them and their
families
and they know who's responsible
they're smart
and as the who sang
they're not going to be fooled again
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else